hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in chapter 8 of his short work what is
art Leo Tolstoy will criticize the art
that's recognized as such in his own
time which we can call the art of the
elites or of the upper classes whether
we associate that in terms of income and
wealth in terms of upper classes or in
terms of opinion formers and those who
have certain competences that are
acknowledged in terms of the elite or
the intersection between the two which
is often the case in many societies
Tolstoy thinks that what they do can be
considered art some of the time but that
much of it is in in some respective
degenerate form of art that aims
primarily at beauty and pleasure and
that their their understanding of art
and that of many theoreticians and
estheticians of the time is far too
narrow so it leaves out all the other
manifestations of what Tolstoy thinks
is genuine art what he calls art in the
broad as opposed to the narrow sense so
the argument that he's actually making
here is that elite art or the art of the
upper classes is not true art not
universal human art but rather something
that is only for a specific group and
that shouldn't be looked at as having a
universal significance that is accorded
to it and we can apply this argument to
our own time I think quite handily as
well see as we go through his
considerations and discussions and
arguments so he says that if art is a
human activity the aim of which is to
convey to others the loftiest and best
feelings people have attained to in life
that's his definition of art there's a
little bit more to it of course but
that's really at the core of what
Tolstoy considers to be the essence of
art it provides a communication and a
communion in feelings and what makes it
really good art is that these are
feelings that are in some way necessary
or wholesome or they reveal to us
something that we were missing out on
before so he says you know this poses a
little problem how could it happen that
mankind should live a certain rather
long period of its life from the time
when people cease to believe in the
church teaching down to the present day
without this important activity and be
satisfied instead with the worthless
activity of art that merely affords
pleasure so there's there's this
devaluation going out on Tolstoy is part
of art and theories of art or
evaluations of art that that Center it
on beauty beauty being understood as
whatever is going to give us pleasure
and and we could you know say that in
the present day there's perhaps not that
much emphasis on beauty in art but there
are other aesthetic qualities
we might associate with it instead that
do we have to do in some respect with
pleasure pleasure understood in a very
broad sense so Tolstoy considers that a
mistaken position he also thinks that we
easily fall into another mistake he says
we have to correct the error people
commonly make in ascribing to our art
the art of us and here he's saying you
know I'm one of the upper classes I can
identify with the ordinary people and
indeed if you look at his life he did a
lot to try to inculcate that in himself
but he knew that he was coming from this
this prioritised or privileged status so
he says our art gets ascribed the
significance of of true universally
human art so he says you might look at
this in nationalistic or racial lines
cultural lines he says we're so used to
regarding naively is the best human race
not just the Caucasian race but the
anglo-saxon if we're English or American
the German if we're German the Gallo
Latin if we're French the Slavic if
we're Russian that when we speak of our
art we are as fully convinced that it is
not only true art but also the best and
the only art and this is indeed quite
common there's there's a sort of
ethnocentrism involved culturally in
pretty much every advanced society that
has its art and as a matter of fact even
those that don't have quite as much
technology or social organization or
earlier in time they all tend to think
that there are is the best art and
Tolstoy says that's not really the case
he says not only is our art not the only
art as the Bible used to be regarded as
the only book but it's not even the art
of all Christian humanity just the art
of a very small section of that part of
humankind so whose is it it's the art of
the upper classes primarily developed
for them appreciated by them
patronizing might not all be produced by
them although they're the ones who often
have the opportunity to go to art school
and have drawing classes and have it
part of their curriculum but it's
certainly oriented towards the
tastemakers and the connoisseurs and
those who have the means for patronage
so you know he goes on and he says that
since the upper classes of the Christian
nations lost their faith in church
Christianity their art became separated
from the art of the whole people and
there have been two arts the art of the
whole people and that of the Masters so
this poses a a real problem the art of
the upper classes becomes viewed as true
and Universal the things that pass as
art among the lower classes or middle
classes are viewed as not really
Universal they're the art of this group
or you know they're of this genre or
this content he actually mentions you
know a little bit later in the work or
it might be a little bit earlier in the
work his surprise at seeing a novelist
saying that there's really not that much
to say about the ordinary peasant
working out in the fields and their
experiences I mean you've seen one
peasant you've pretty much seen them all
but you know when it comes to like the
things that the upper classes are
interested in like fine liqueurs and
having love affairs and dueling and
things like that then they can go into
minut detail right and we see this still
playing itself up we have discussions
about representation today particularly
in the art fields of TV and film and
things where people are resent
represented medically there and then we
can say well you know we need to
represent other people's experience so
Tolstoy has a few considerations that he
wants to bring before us
one thing and I think that you know this
is still a good charge right now he says
most people have little to no contact
with the art of the elites he says if
we're gonna say that the art we possess
is the whole of art the true the only
art then not only do 2/3 of the human
race in his time all the peoples of Asia
and Africa live and die without knowing
this only true art but furthermore
barely 1% of the people in our own
Christian societies talking about the
Russia of the 19th century benefit from
this art which we call the whole of art
the remaining 99% of our European people
live and die by generations working hard
without ever tasting this art so you
know we could say it's gotten better in
our own time
not only have many art museums been
created and you know field trips and
opportunities and things like that but
there are many people who really never
do encounter what we would call high art
right and that that would be a problem
if indeed the art of the elites and the
upper classes is supposed to be
universal art so we don't one of the
possibilities then as well what if we
reorganize Society what if we change the
conditions so that ordinary people could
in fact get access to to this art he
says here's here's an objection they'll
say it's not the art to blame but the
wrong organization of society and then
notice what he says next it's possible
to imagine that in the future physical
labor will be partly replaced by
machines will partly be lightened by its
proper distribution and the work of
producing art will be done in terms that
there's no need for the same people can
constantly to sit under the stage moving
the scenery lifting machinery and
playing on the piano or the French horn
or setting type and printing books and
those who do
all that can work a small number of
hours a day and their free time benefit
from all the blessings of art so he's
talking about it's not even really a
utopian reorganization of society
because I would say that in our own time
we have significantly realized that
think about the fact that I record video
lectures granted these are not art but
we could make them Arts if we wanted to
right and I do so on technology that is
very cheaply and readily available I
have a voice recorder I have a you know
camera that's rather inexpensive a
tripod which we purchased for I think
twenty five dollars to lighting kits
purchased for fifty dollars a piece a
blackboard purchased years and years ago
which I'll be using probably the rest of
my career and then I suppose you could
say that you know the bandwidth the
internet access and the clothing that
I'm wearing are also investments in that
as well and then the knowledge that I
have up in my head and and the books
right it's relatively easy these days to
do a lot of things you want music to put
into your video
well there's free music out there that
you can access as a matter of fact great
classical music on moves open or YouTube
has some as well and so maybe there's
some case to saying that there's much
wider possibility of distribution
technology has come in and leveled the
playing field both for producers and for
the access of consumers or appreciators
so Tolstoy says they cannot be unaware
the people who say this that our refined
art could emerge only on the slavery of
the popular masses and can continue only
as long as this slavery exists and that
the specialist writers musicians dancers
and actors can reach that refined degree
of perfection only on condition of the
hard work of laborers and that only on
these conditions
can there exist the refined public to
appreciate such works free the slaves of
capital and it'll be impossible to
produce such refined art now we should
think about this you know it's possible
to be an artist
and put your work out there on the
Internet let's say your your graphic
designer you can put your work out on
multiple sites have your own website
aren't you still participating in an
economy though that in some ways is
going to support you the answer is yes
and it's not as easy to disentangle
yourself when you think about all the
things you need clothing food you know
electricity Wi-Fi all those things do in
fact involve somebody doing some work
even you know the entire gig economy
that's replacing a lot of current work
and does involve you know a lot of human
labour still artists rely on that as
well so you know this is something to
keep in mind he also points out another
important factor he says that even if we
admit the inadmissable that methods can
be found to make it possible for all
people to benefit from art another
consideration presents itself
why present-day art cannot be the whole
of art namely maybe overplaying his hand
a little bit here it is totally
incomprehensible for the people it says
poetic works were once written in Latin
but nowadays works of art or is
incomprehensible for the people as if
they were written in Sanskrit so this
the usual reply is that if people don't
understand our art now it only proves
that they're underdeveloped exactly as
it's been with every new step in art so
then the key is to instead of you know
complaining about that give people art
appreciation courses or music
appreciation courses or other means that
they can use to get something
out of it there are indeed some forms of
art that are more demotic you could say
more of the people that get elevated and
then people can appreciate you know if
you think about popular music that that
provides a lot of great examples or you
know to some degree street art and
murals those those are you know often
easy to relate to but going to the
average art museum and get past the you
know representational art and get into
the 20th century stuff and you walk up
to things you're like what in the hell
is this and what am I supposed to make
of it and being told by the artist you
know things like wow I don't want to
influence your interpretation art is
whatever you make of it it's
understandable why ordinary people can
shrug their shoulders and say I this art
III guess so I I don't know what the
hell am I looking at here and we could
say the same for performance art or
installations you know there's there's a
lot of things like this where people
they can't relate to it and so Tolstoy
says that the defenders of present-day
art say that we just need to educate
people and he points out something
really interesting here again he says we
know the majority of upper-class works
of art such as various now notice what
he's calling upper-class art and his
time oh it's narrative poems dramas
cantatas pastoral paintings and so on
which upper-class people admired in
their time have never afterwards been
either understood or appreciated by the
great masses and remained what they
always were an amusement for wealthy
people of their time for whom alone they
had significance and we can conclude the
same will happen to our own art he's
writing in the late 1800s and we can say
the same about art in the 20th century
and art in the 21st century so he says
that when to prove that people will in
time come to understand our art
said that some works of so-called
classic poetry music and painting which
the masses did not like at first they
began to like later after these works
were offered to them from all sides and
he says well this doesn't really prove
the case all this proves is that if you
throw enough stuff at people and say you
better get behind this they will indeed
begin to appreciate it to some degree
but they probably won't get out of it
what it is that you want so for example
let's just think of a possibility a
great you know
character for moral deliberation in
ancient philosophy and literature was
that of Medea and Euripides in fact
wrote a play called the Medea other
people tried their hand at it as well so
what if we take this figure of Medea and
we just like you know make sure that
every time that art comes up we talk
about Madana why you should see this
play or why you should read it and why
you should look at the pictorial
representations in painting or sculpture
and all that and we just shove it down
people's throats well sooner or later
people are gonna get the idea yeah I got
think of Medea is pretty important but
that doesn't mean that they're actually
going to appreciate that art the Greek
you know drama the literature the
paintings or any of that sort of thing
they made to say well you know I like
the chariot she drives I wish I had one
of those or oh it's a terrible thing she
killed her kids you know sort of like
that that case over there in Texas or
you know they'll make the wrong
associations and he says that this art
is not produced by by the masses or the
mob and it's not chosen by them it's
forcefully thrust upon them in public
places where they have access to art so
like he says that which constitutes
pleasure for a person of the wealthy
classes is not perceived as pleasure by
a working person calls up in them either
no feelings at all or feelings
completely contrary to those it calls up
in an idle and satiated person we could
think about this with you know the
popularity of certain shows
we watch you know a great example of
this our shows about rich people there
probably aren't that many rich people
watching the Housewives or you know
these other shows set about people who
you know are going through these these
troubles these sort of reality shows
which are quite popular in the the
general public different kinds of tastes
are involved not that you know I think
Tolstoy would say that the the
Housewives shows are actually genuine
art either but Tolstoy would say that
what's really important is that we find
art that can actually appeal to
everybody and he leaves us with a
central dilemma he says all of these
considerations lead us to the point
where we're faced with a choice which of
these are we going to choose either we
say art itself is not really that
important this vital dimension of human
existence something that we see every
culture once it you know reaches a
certain stage engaging in is that no
longer important or is it that the art
that we call art namely the art of the
elites and upper classes the masters as
he says that's not that important and if
that's not that important then Tolstoy
is view is we need to further the
development of a different kind of art
art for the people genuinely universal
art
you